[音楽]
panamera
初めまして戦闘で円形を支えている
田中みずきと申しますよろしくお願いします
[拍手]
私は
大学時代に美術史を勉強していてそこで卒業論文で戦闘の弁慶について調べて
でそれをきっかけにして今の仕事をしています
首相のもとに嬉しいでスタート4年前から今日も来てくれている
便利屋の駒村夫とですね一緒にペン型を製作しています
さてこの中で
この1年の間に先頭に行かれた方
手をあげてみてくださいを
なんかもうすぐ多いですね
ありがとうございます
赤青
今はどうなのかなぁと思っていたんですけれども結構8割ぐらいの方が手を挙げて
くださってありがとうございます
今日今ですね手を上げてくださらなかった方もこのお話の後で戦闘に興味持って
ぜひ行って頂ければと思います
それではあ
ですね私の円形についてお話をしていきたいとおもいます
まずですね
こちら
壁いっぱいに書かれているんですけれども足立区の港北遺産というところで書かれて
いる
弁慶です
こちら仕様ダックの稲荷うさんという銭湯です
大変カラフルな色でこの時は制作をさせていただきました
そして
こちら第2寿第2寿湯さん失礼しました
動画が区の銭湯です
なかなか爽やかな絵になっているかと思います
さて
全然関係ないんですけれどもちょっと余談で実は今ご覧いただいていた
ペン型なんですが
戦闘がお休みの日1日で政策を仕上げまして使う天気
こちら ahkah
大きいの三原色と後ろこの4色のみで絵を書いていきます
無死先頭に行かれたらこうちょっと
連れていってる友達とかですね上書きするとちょっと数な感じがするのでぜひ実践して
いただければと思います
さて先ほどご覧いただいていた絵なんですけれども
3枚に共通して書かれていたモチーフがあったことお気づきでしょうか
皆さんおそらく心の中で答えていらっしゃるかと思います
おじさんです
第2寿に関しては背景の富士山に合わせて手前の方に富士山をモチーフにした
江戸川区の浴場組合のキャラクター荻野藤くんというダブル富士になっていると言う l
した
なお
こちらですね
ご覧いただいているとおそらく
銭湯のペンキ絵って言ったら富士山だよねと思ってくださるかと思います
ところが申し訳ありません私こういった妹を書いております
株式会社れちゃいさんの広告で
可能なツアーの行動でしたロッキー山脈書いております
このほかにですね
アウディジャパンですね facebook の20万年
マンいい女大記念して書いたペン型になっています
また昨年書かせて頂いたものなんですけれども
昨年公開19002016年ですねすいません2016年公開のシンゴジラの映画に
合わせて2位になった大田区の風景と一緒に絵を描かせていただきました
ペンキ絵に広告を書くというお仕事です
こういった愛を書いているとあーなんか変形に富士山じゃなくて高校各なって新しい
ことをやっているんだねと言われます
新しいペン型として
受け取っていただいてるんだなぁと思います
でも自分はちょっとひねくれているのでこう聞かれるとそうなんだろうかと思って
しまいます
果たしてこういった試み新しいのだろうか
そう思ってしまうのはおそらく私が大学時代に勉強していた
美術史の
まあ知識で
どんなことを考えていくかという考え方を学んでいたからかと思います
今も
仕事をする上で役立っているんですがたった3つです
一つ目が歴史を調べる
二つ目が時代背景を考える
ニーズに合わせてどんな作品が作られているかってことを調べて
してどんな時代家だったかってことを確認していきます
3つ目現代的に解釈し直す
12で見えてきた自分にとってこれが本質なんじゃないかと思えることを今の時代だと
同組変えていけるかということを考えていきます
さてこの3つに合わせて
今の広告の円形についてどんなことを考えてきたか話ししたいと思います
まず銭湯のペンキ屋の過去なんですけれども
そもそも
先頭のペン型は
広告描写が制作をしていました
こちらですね先ほどご覧いただいていたいなんですけれども
下の方に
近所の店の広告が並んでいたことを機好きでいらっしゃいましたでしょうか
昔昭和の時代には銭湯に行くとたくさん並んでいたんですけれどもこれ大正時代から
こういったシステムありまして
て
先頭の広告を出していただいてその広告費で
サービスでペン型が書で変えられるというシステムがありました
そこで銭湯のペンキを書く職人は報復会社2足数という形で絵を書いていたんです
大正時代ですねどんな企業が広告を出してたかっていうのを調べていきますと
実はですね中山対応度今の株式会社クラブコスメチックスさんまんですけれども
心無広告を出しておられまして
歯磨きの広告でですね
富士山を使っていらっしゃるのですね
これ1回限りではなくて
富士山の高さをご覧頂ければと思うんですけれども
こんな感じで
どんどんどんどんですね富士山
めちゃくちゃ盛り上がってくるっていう
富士山の地下がすごいなって形になってくるんですけれどもこういった形で実は先頭の
壁にも83
新聞にも富士山という形でこの企業の広告を展開しておられたようです
これ今考えると企業の cm と
例えばインターネットだったり新聞だったりって広告を出すときにイメージ
キャラクター
同じイメージキャラクターで広告を展開していくそういった形に近いのかもしれません
もちろん富士山が定着していた理由はたくさんあるかと思うんですが
その理由として一つこのことを知っていると
ペン型
ついての見方というものが変わってくるかと思います
地下ですね
1970年4個純情さんの戦闘のペン型という
話の中にはですねなこの句のセントに
ご近所のお店の広告でハワイの絵が書いてあったと
そんな m 音が書いてあったりとか
あるいは1979年の雑誌スーパーとさんがと
線とのペン型についての特集が組まれていてうちの会社は積極的に天地に広告を変えて
います
といった報告が医者の
メンバーとがですね掲載されています
グラビアと一緒に写真がもう
掲載されていて
deko たジャケットを書いて
3日間かかったなんていうことも書いてあったでしょ
をご覧いただくと電気への一部は
報告であったということを
少し分かりいただけたかと思います
さて戦闘での広告だんだん少なくなってきます
なぜかというとみなさんご存じのように
前ホームのブームが起きたりユニットバス学校
んその家に荒れるようになって千本利用者が減ってきます
1965年昭和40年には2641キャント線と今は2017年
600軒ぐらいになってきております
このときに空区富士山の女美川ということが起きてきてしまいます
その中で世の中の経済活動と戦闘というものが隔離していくような商業が生まれてきて
しまいます
その時自分が考えたのが
こちらですね
a
インターネットを使って
世の中と戦闘というものをまたつなぐことができないかということでした
私が大学生の頃位2000年代な
2000台2丁党なんですけれども
日本ではブログのシステムが
一般の方も使えるようになって big c というですね
のエッセんですがはぁ
すごく好盛り上がってきた時代でしてその時私は
あれですねー
節で全然顔も知らない方からアドバイスを受けました
先頭の情報があまりにもないと自分はメディアで働いているんだけど
先頭の中の様子があまりにもないからもしこれをネットで提供したら絶対に需要がある
からやってみなさいというコメントでした
本当だろうかアウト
気になっていたんですけれどもやってみたらいろんな方が自分の書いたミクシィの記事
のところに来てくれていることが分かりました
その中には確かにメディアの方イベント関係の方もいたことがわかります
ここで
やっていたのが
伝統新光社というところの活動です
こちらですね先ほどの報告なんですけれども実はこの戦闘新校舎のペン蛍光
プロジェクトという中で
再会をしました
これですね一見県先頭のマイナー伏せ未定魚んで
慣れない口調で
8して言ってそうするとありがたい事に広告出してくださるところがあって
こういった感じで報告を今制作しています
あの雨加工イメージ像を作っていって
長い子を文言だと読みづらいですよとか言いながらも
利酒師が選ぶ革秀寺さっき大切なんだとか
氷点下無策勝利なんですとか言われてじゃあ分かりますと残しますって言ってもう一杯
作って相談をしていくみたいなことをしていきます
あとこれとか無茶苦茶料理おいしいが日上位の a ではなくて亀が書いてあるのはご
主人が亀が好きと言う
ただ
それだけの理由でこの広告になっています
でですね何をやっていたかというと
私はこの活動しながらずーっとこういった活動を
ローブにもせるということを指摘続けました
インターネットと戦闘とペン型この3つを繋げた時におそらく何か新しい経済の仕組み
ができるそう思って本当にこれ効果あるのか
言われ続けながらどんどんどんどん自分が入ってか行かせていただいたペンキ絵のこと
であったり
皆外時代も師匠について
この情報を出していくってことをし続けました
てそうしているなかれ
独立してから1年ですねある日テーマがかかってきて
ロッキー山脈が書けるかと
そこから先ほどの広告の写真ねと話がつながってきます
つためにこちら私のブログになってまして今もこれ新しい情報を出し続けています
おそらく自分は先ほどお伝えしたこの3つの考え方でこれからも
今やれることというのを考えていくと思いますおそらくコレ一つ一つは全く新しいこと
ではないんですけれどもこの3つを組み合わせたときに新しいもの今しか見れない物
っていうものができていくんじゃないかと思っています
ぜひぜひ
光学以外にも今いろんなプロジェクト仕掛けておりますので皆さん
先頭で目撃していただければと思います
天気見ていくと結構
医師によって五色町が違っていて明るい絵だったりすごく
ちゃくちゃ落ち着くなってだったりたくさんような衆院が会がありますぜひぜひ
戦闘で素敵な時間あと円形ぜひ1回ちょっとじっくり眺めて頂ければと思います
ありがとうございました
[拍手]